now let's explore terraform an open
source infrastructure as code tool
you saw in the last section how manually
creating an environment in Google Cloud
can be a labor-intensive task and how
using a template can make the process
more efficient
terraform is an open source tool that
lets you use templates to provision
Google Cloud resources
to use terraform you create a template
file by using hashicor configuration
language HCL which describes what the
components of the environment should
look like
terraform then uses that template to
determine the actions needed to create
the environment your template describes
if you need to change the environment
you can edit your template and then use
terraform to update the environment to
match the change
a deployment can be repeated as many
times as required with consistent
results and you can delete an entire
deployment with one command or click
terraform uses the underlying apis of
each Google cloud service to deploy your
resources
this enables you to deploy almost
everything we've seen so far from
instances instance templates and groups
to VPC networks firewall rules VPN
tunnels Cloud routers and load balancers
you can also store and Version Control
your terraform templates in Cloud Source
repositories
in addition to terraform Google Cloud
also provides support for other
third-party open source IAC tools